what's going on guys welcome back to
geek culture explained my name is rob
and in this video i'm gonna be revealing
how it is that i know that odin and the
ancient one
both knew about the eternals but why it
is that neither of them got a hold of
the eternals when everything started
popping off during the events of
infinity war and avengers in-game and
even during thor ragnarok when hella
appeared so let's talk about odin for a
second in the marvel cinematic universe
we don't really know how old odin
is all we get is a kind of reference
point in thor ragnarok when odin talks
about how they live they die and that's
just the way that life is
and loki says give or take five thousand
years now we're assuming the apples of a
dune do not exist in the marvel
cinematic universe those of you guys who
don't know what that is in marvel comics
the apples of a dune are actually apples
that the asgardians eat
which prolong their lives there is a
kind of offhanded or at least assumed
concept in the marvel cinematic universe
that they exist
but we don't know definitively there
have been rumors that odin is actually
much older than that that odin's been
around for like 500 million years
i don't know if that's true that number
seems really really high but let's
assume for example the eternals are
modeled after marvel comics and the
eternals came into existence or at least
were made into existence by the
celestials some 30
000 years ago well that would mean that
they existed 25 000 years before odin
was
essentially odin or possibly even born
but even if that's the case
odin would still have to know that they
exist how because of heimdall heimdall
sees everything and when i mean
everything i mean
everything everything from the
individual person who's doing something
to everything going on in the world at
the same time and even if the eternals
had been hiding their identities from
the world
there had to be a few instances when
they slipped up which makes me think
that heimdall knew that they existed
heimdall of course would tell odin this
and odin would in turn realized this was
the case
which begs the question why didn't odin
intervene we'll answer that here in a
minute now let's move to the ancient one
the ancient one of course was the
sorcerer supreme who existed before
doctor strange before the ancient one
was sorcerer supreme we don't
definitively know who it was
but we do know the original sorcerer
supreme was agamoto some
however many number of years ago we're
not really given a definitive time frame
there but the overall gist of this was
up until her death the ancient one was
the foremost authority on mystic arts
meaning the ancient one seemingly kind
of knew everything that was going on
i have a hard time believing that a
being out there that has full knowledge
of the multiverse and all the dangers in
it
would not know the eternals were on
earth that seems kind of silly and so
that means the ancient one had to know
the eternals were there so the question
is why didn't we see the eternals during
the events of avengers in-game sure i
guess we could ask the question why
didn't doctor strange get a hold of them
but
it's kind of hard to get a hold of
anybody and ask for help when you've
basically been wiped from existence so i
guess we could turn that question into
why didn't doctor strange seek out the
help of the eternals at the end of
infinity war so we could see them in
avengers in-game
my assumption having the eternals
intervene and fight on behalf of the
superheroes was one of the 14 million
possibilities that doctor strange saw
and he knew it didn't work if he knew
it's not going to work what's the point
of doing it so
ultimately we never saw the eternals now
the big question we also have to ask is
why didn't odin and why didn't the
ancient one get a hold of the eternals
well the other big assumption people are
making here is that odin and the ancient
one never actually met each other
there's no indication that that's the
case i have to believe that again the
ancient one given her vast knowledge of
the multiverse and the inner workings of
dimensions and so on and so forth
may have somehow stumbled across odin or
perhaps the two of them had a brief
conversation
don't really know maybe something akin
to the same way that thor
met doctor strange or loki met doctor
strange and then he sent loki flying
through those portals
that was amazing
i have been falling for 30 minutes
but even if they did contact the
eternals assuming the eternal's film is
falling in line with marvel comics one
of the things that we covered in both
our reaction video as well as our
trailer breakdown for the eternals
is that the celestials do not want
anybody else meddling in the affairs of
regular men
because at the end of the day humanity
is just a big experiment by the
celestials
and if that's the case it's more likely
if the eternals were contacted their
response was
no you cannot intervene with anybody or
the celestials will destroy you
and as powerful as odin is and as
powerful as the ancient one was if the
celestials are anything like they are in
marvel comics
they would obliterate both of them with
that being said guys let me know what
you all think down in the comments
section i'm curious what your idea is on
this theory and i will catch you all
later
peace